Tadashi: Piece of red string,
and, I threaded it through, a binder clip.
The binder clip is carrying a passenger underneath.
Let's say that this is a top of a mountain,
and we are designing a funicular.
I want to carry this passenger up to the top of the mountain, summit of the mountain.
How can you do this?
One solution is to just, uh, widen the string *cracks up* like this,
and then make the whole thing go upward.
But I don't think the engineers will accept this solution.
So, what we do, is to keep those two strings absolutely parallel,
no cheating,
but then tug on them in alternating fashion.
So tug, tug, tug, tug, and look!
The clip...
starts going up, spontaneously,
toward the summit of the mountain.
That's strange, right?
Because...
if you are just looking at the vicinity of my hands,
what I'm doing is up and down, up and down,
and it's a purely symmetric motion, up and down, up and down.
So there's no directionality,
and if anything, gravity's pointing downward.
I mean this should keep coming down,
but instead, by doing a completely symmetric up-and-down motion,
I can take this thing upward,
in a way that breaks the symmetry, yeah?
Prefers to go up, and not come down.
So, that is rather strange.
And the wonderful thing about this is that it works even if you're not paying attention.
You know, it's a really simple device,
and even if you're, uh, not paying attention,
and being distracted by, for example, my friend, uh, Brady there,
I can just do this, and then...
wait a minute, it's coming down, instead.
So, and that's, that's wrong.
So, I am just watching the [unintelligible].
No no, it's coming down, no, it's not going up.
What is going...
Whereas, you know, you find, "I'm paying attention."
And, okay, so this is, uh, the device.
And, if, if I were paying, paying attention,
I'm not being distracted by the camera or anything,
then I can do this, focus, parallel,
and tug, tug, tug, it does go up. [funicular tugging noise]
Brady: Hehehe, All right, what's going on here?
Tadashi: What we are doing,
suppose that, keeping the strings parallel,
I tug on the left one,
whereas, I let go of the right one.
And when they do this initially,  you see...
To exaggerate a little,
this clip turns a little, like this.
But that means, you see, that this string is touching the left part of the clip
only lightly. Whereas the right one is
entangled with the clip
so this produces more friction
And in fact the static friction
whereas this can slide and that's dynamic friction
and we discussed that dynamic friction is slightly smaller than static friction
when i do this, this static friction wants to pull the clip down
and this friction wants to push the clip up
but because the right friction is the static and entangled friction
and the left one is the sliding and free friction
and this push up is stronger than this pull down
that's why in this rope it goes up
and similarly when I pull the right one and left one
Now it twists like this
left one gets pulled up by the stronger friction
whereas the right one which is now pretty free
can slide along the string and doesn't pull down
so that's why I mean going back and forth, back and forth like this
even if we keep it horizontal
I mean this up and down business is a red herring
it is purely a function of how the string is threaded through the binder clip
that determines which way it goes
if I do it for example, down
it still goes because the binder clip is threaded that way
when I turn it around
then the binder clip comes my way
or downward it's the same thing
oops ahh hehe sorry maybe that's the end of the experiment I have to
have a okay, we got it, we got it
okay I have to have some more tape
behaves exactly the same way
whereas forty-five degrees off
you get the...